the next time that you're afraid the
next time you're feeling small the next
time you're worried about somebody
else's opinions of you that you go and
you take action that you do the thing
because you cannot play small for life
if you are worried about what people
think of you you will never accomplish
the big goals in your business because
you have big goals you're an
entrepreneur you want to do amazing
things you have big Ambitions that will
never happen if you're afraid of what
one person is going to think of you
because as your vision is bigger the
more people are going to attack you and
you need to develop that thick skin and
ask yourself how can I do it how can I
take my Approach with as much caring
compassion understanding as possible but
I need to get out there and put my
message forward